hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar procalcitonin and it's
important in the emergency department
I'm Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by bu Mariya a world
leader in the field of in vitro
diagnostics for over fifty five years bu
mariya is present in 43 countries and
serves more than 160 countries with the
support of a large network of
distributors numeri o provides
diagnostic solutions systems reagents
software and services which determine
the source of disease and contamination
to improve patient health and ensure
consumer safety its products are mainly
used for diagnosing infectious diseases
and some critical illnesses the
company's diagnostic solutions are also
used for detecting microorganisms in
agri-food
pharmaceutical and cosmetic products to
learn more visit WWE
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left of your screen labeled ask
a question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Daniel J
Feinstein F ACP and associate clinical
professor of medicine at the University
of North Carolina School of
Edinson dr. Feinstein trained in
internal medicine in Baltimore at st.
Agnes Hospital and then at Rush Medical
Center for critical care medicine he is
an adult intensivist and has performed
research in septic shock and antibiotic
administration dr. Weinstein has been a
pioneer in antibiotic stewardship and
sepsis care dr. Weinstein will now begin
his presentation
thank you for the introduction it's
great to be here I'm excited to discuss
the topic of procalcitonin is used
specifically in the emergency department
I'm an intensivist full time and I think
I've had a unique opportunity to be in
the emergency room quite a bit and then
continue to take care of these patients
during admission to the intensive care
unit and the step down the floors so it
allows me to have a reasonable
understanding in terms of the sepsis
transitions and sepsis care
to you to do research specifically
around sepsis and procalcitonin and
lactic acid and continue to be a
consultant with beer and where you
for today's talk we are going to talk
specifically on procalcitonin use in the
emergency department we're going to go
over the introduction the
pharmacokinetics of PCT we're going to
look at PCT use in using it as a tool
and differential diagnosis in terms of
distinguishing the difference between
viral and bacterial infections we'll
look at the positive predictive value of
using PCT for early identification in
sepsis patients we'll look at the
emergency rooms need of using PCT for
antibiotic stewardship and then we'll
look at triaging in the ER and the value
of PCT on triaging and the outcomes and
using that as a predictive model on some
decision-making and then lastly we'll
close looking at lower respiratory
infections in in the emergency room and
those patients who get admitted or even
be dis are discharged from the ER
so everyone is very familiar with sepsis
if you're not excited about sepsis now
then I don't think you will ever be
excited about sepsis because it's just a
huge focus throughout our country right
about now there's probably about 1.15
million incidents of sepsis predicting
in the year in 2020 and so it's a very
common cause of death in the United
States unfortunately and despite all the
awareness and guidelines and and the
surviving sepsis guidelines and the
bundles we still have some work to be
done in sepsis care in particular the
antibiotic stewardship piece and the
potential negative aspects of providing
aggressive antibiotics fluids etc to
patients who who would don't you meet
criteria for sepsis
I know a large majority or familiar with
surviving sepsis campaign and then the
subsequent CMS bundle which in general
mirrors surviving sepsis campaign the
three-hour bundle very important and the
six-hour bundle follow-up and addressing
hypotension we're all charged to be very
aggressive which we should be in cases
of sepsis and when I look at PCT and
where this potentially fits in it's
really on two to two ends the first end
being early identification if you can't
identify these patients and sometimes we
don't
we have delays to identification then we
can't initiate the surviving sepsis
campaign bundle and and and try to
improve outcomes on the flip side are
the are the I guess the issues in terms
of over utilization and providing
aggressive sepsis care in those cases
that in the end did not turn out to be
sepsis and using PCT potentially for its
negative predictive value of the
discontinuation of antibiotics that were
are not necessary further
we use biomarkers on a daily basis
troponin x' and BMPs and cortisol levels
and PCT lactic acid levels all of these
are biomarkers and they aid in risk
stratification they can help us with
prognostication they can identify the
presence or absence of a disease such as
sepsis we can monitor a response to
patients our to our intervention such as
antibiotics we can use PCT as a
biomarker to serve as a surrogate
endpoint for discontinuation of
antibiotics so there's multiple roles
that for PCT and we're going to cover a
large majority of those specifically in
the emergency room
so let's start off by having some some
very important knowledge in terms of
procalcitonin kinetics how is it
produced and then talk briefly about
some of the false elevations of PCT in
inflammatory conditions
so procalcitonin is produced primarily
in our thyroid at baseline some in our
lungs and it starts out as pre
procalcitonin 140 plus amino acid
structure and it rises in the setting of
a bacterial infection and serves which
is important sometimes I get questions
in terms of basic urinary tract
infections for patients and unless they
have sirs PCT is not going to mount a
significant response PCT fortunately
Rises very quickly within 3 to 6 hours
it has a half-life of about 22 hours and
can aid in early identification of
patients with sepsis and bacterial
infections with serves in the setting of
bacterial infection and serves it starts
getting pumped out at a hundred thousand
times the traditional baseline levels of
PCT and at that point PCT is being
produced by thyroid and lungs but organs
in our abdomen organs and our additional
in our brain multiple other organs start
producing in a PCT
in healthy individuals at baseline PCT
concentrations are less than 0.05
nanograms per milliliter but in a
setting again of a bacterial infection
in sirs you see this rapid rise of PCT
and what's been very important to note
is that as a patient acuity gets worse
PCT will continue to rise within that
host until infection is controlled and
treated appropriately
P see if he can be elevated in some rare
neuroendocrine tumors I've never seen
that maybe I wasn't looking hard enough
but more commonly is PCT elevation in
other inflammatory conditions such as
post cabbage or valve replacement a
trauma patients burns bad pancreatitis
bad a RDS and those levels if you can
use PCT but just recognize that in those
illnesses that are just inflammation PCT
gets to this kind of two three four five
range and kind of stays flat very
similarly is patients with end-stage
renal disease patients with end-stage
renal disease can have low level PCT
elevations at baseline related to their
lack of clearance but in all these
groups I'm just talking to you about
inflammatory conditions if you see PCT
that's at these two three four five and
then it jumps up and rises to ten
fifteen etc maybe in a VAT patient that
certainly can be useful an indicative of
a new infections infectious process
so PCT has been FDA cleared since 2007
at that time it was for to aid in risk
assessment for sepsis and septic shock
specifically on the first day of ICU
admission in the emergency room and
since then in 2016 the FDA looked at a
good bit of meta-analysis and good data
that then cleared procalcitonin juice
for what i've been using it for since
2010 which is to aid in antibiotic
discontinuation antibiotic stewardship
the negative predictive value in the
same cohort of this Cochrane analysis
the FDA looked at they also approved
procalcitonin for lower respiratory
tract infection use such as communica at
ammonia which 80% is viral acute
exacerbations of COPD and bronchitis
which we're going to discuss
so let's talk about the use of PCT in
the ER for trying to differentiate viral
versus bacterial infections and then
other non-infectious causes of illness
medicine is hard and these patients just
present very similarly patients with
pneumonia patients with viral
pneumonitis patients with autoimmune
pneumonitis other other non infectious
pneumonia
even heart failure these they all
present differently and so you need as
much help as you can get to try to help
differentiate their cause of their
disease fortunately it looks like with
with bacterial infection
lipopolysaccharide produces specific
cytokines and then you have this kind of
robust again production of pre pre
procalcitonin which eventually gets
cleaved to PCT in viral infections
however interferon gamma is produced
which essentially blocks the production
of procalcitonin and therefore you can
use this to try and differentiate
between mono viral infections and then
patients who have bacterial illness on
top
again rises rapidly after this bacterial
insult and it offers a pretty good
specificity for differentiating a
bacterial infection versus just true and
true inflammation alone the studies are
pretty good on this some as large as
about 300 patients looking at trying to
differentiate viral by itself versus
viral plus super infection or bacterial
infection on its own
this is a study that tries to look at
look at a specific value or a cutoff to
try to differentiate between sepsis and
non-infectious sirs or just inflammation
and this is a meta-analysis 30 studies
including about over 3,000 patients
looking at the sensitivity and
specificity more of a lab sensitivity
and specificity but it seemed to find a
sweet spot or of a value of about 2 or
2.2 we're above that you really should
be you know concern that a bacterial
infection is present
is again just trying to really reiterate
the the levels very significantly
elevated in patients who are having
bacterial illness versus a viral illness
where interferon-gamma is inhibiting the
release of PCT and somewhat similarly is
fungal infection fungal infection as
well you can have some low-level PCT but
overall stays stays statistically
significantly lower than those with
bacterial infection
this is a similar idea looking at PCP
levels being bound much higher in this
study in intensive care medicine 2011 on
those patients who had bacterial
co-infections
who also had a viral illness versus
those patients who had a viral illness
alone
let's talk about the positive predictive
value in the emergency room looking at
how can we identify these patients with
sepsis where maybe before we really are
clinical know-how alone could not
identify them and then some of these
cases of which which anyone online who
has used pre CT you're going to get
surprised you're going to see some
levels that are elevated significantly
and really is very helpful in terms of
initiating steps of care like most and
all blood tests no one should be using
procalcitonin by itself it's all about
using your clinical judgment your
clinical know-how and combining it you
can see with PCT you see the area under
the curve getting larger and having
improved sensitivity and specificity for
sepsis patients
slide that looks at PCTs receiver
operator curve with sensitivity and
specificity and it looks pretty good you
know in the ICU and the emergency room
we use a lot of tests and you know none
of them are perfect and neither is
procalcitonin but overall when you
compare to everything else we have for
sepsis care it does a pretty good job I
want to draw your attention to the green
line with lactic acid we need lactic
acid we we should continue to use it for
perfusion status it is not something
that any all any of us use to
discontinue antibiotics and we should
always recognize how nonspecific lactic
acid is it rises with glucophage and
cardiogenic shock and it rises with
hypovolemic shock and it's obviously a
very non non
so actually right now I'm involved in a
study of a thousand patients trying to
use PCT and lactic acid and see if
they're synergistic in the valuation of
our patients in the emergency room
this is data from my group with Anna and
Kumar where in 2006 was published in
critical care medicine we we looked at
retrospective data looking at septic
shock patients and discovered of course
where for every hour and delay after
patients fail fluid resuscitation
there was a 7.6 percent rise in
mortality so we do our very best as
clinicians some of these patients get
delayed to diagnosis after numerous
cases where again I was surprised by a
positive procalcitonin of 30 or 40 or 50
never thought I'd see it but it really
was the the only thing that really
tipped me off to considering antibiotic
and Pyrrhic antibiotic use again
medicine is very difficult we got to
kind of use every tool we have in a
toolbox to try to take care of patients
in our study we found that when patients
received appropriate antibiotics well in
this case within 30 minutes and that was
82% 82% of the patients their survival
of 77%
within one hour of antibiotic
administration you can see the survival
fraction of the longer you go with
delaying antibiotics really mortality
unfortunately Rises just drastically
this phenomenon of being able to
identify patients as quickly as possible
and being able to treat them and trying
to reduce mortality the phenomenon that
we found with a seven point six percent
mortality increase when we delayed the
diagnosis and treatment within what was
found in all cultures it didn't matter
if you were bacteremic or not didn't
matter where you came from in terms of
community or near the chromium didn't
matter if you were culture positive work
culture negative it stood it also didn't
matter in terms of the source and it
also didn't matter in terms of the
organism so again it just becomes
crucial to identify these patients as
fast as possible and start antibiotics
in terms of lactic acid again we should
not be substituting PCT for lactic acid
we should be continued to use lactic
acid for perfusion status this is a
study of emergency room patients 840
adults and it looked at patients lactic
acid levels and looking at mortality in
severe sepsis patients and regardless of
you few were in shock or not if you're
lactic acid was elevated regardless of
your blood pressure was low or not it
was a poor predictor and you were going
to do worse so if you think about that
the times of patients quote-unquote
looking good with lactic acid of 8.5
with diagnosis of sepsis are kind of
over of not being aggressive for them so
being able to identify them and
correlate that with lactic acid and
patient presentation with the use of PCT
it can be very very helpful
when patients clear their lactic acids
that's what we want patients patients do
better but again it all goes back to
using everything we have in our toolbox
of having a rapid identification process
in the emergency room in the triage of
identifying these patients rapidly and
if you have an elevated PCT that
potentially can can help you get to
treatment faster
let's talk about antibiotic stewardship
and we'll talk about getting a baseline
PCT in the emergency room which of
course goes with a negative predictive
value when I first set up a sepsis
program and in my prior health system
the emergency room doctors fortunately
understood this that we had to if I
didn't get a baseline from from from
them it made things a little more
difficult interpretation of using PCT
for its negative predictive value over
time
we all know that inappropriate
antibiotics is a huge problem in our
country and it creates major safety
issues it's estimated at two million
illnesses a year in the United States
and 23 thousand deaths which is probably
overwhelmingly C this comes from
inappropriate antibiotic utilization
I really I really like this next slide
because I think it's an important thing
to understand
cultures in the ER and we and we and we
treat and that's what we should be doing
she always rely on our clinical mel hell
with aggressive treatments for what we
think is sepsis in the emergency room
and then kind of get our PCT and let the
dust settle a little bit later we have
to recognize that we get ourselves in a
gray area for two or three days where
cultures are pending which we're lying
of course on their clinical know-how
fifty percent of patients are
culture-negative who come in with sepsis
and septic shock 15 to about 20 and some
studies thirty percent of the time we
don't know the source
so PCT and our clinical know-how it's
kind of really what we can have during
this time period of trying to determine
patients needs for antibiotics and even
escalation of care
the study which is an outpatient study
which i think is actually published on
the cdc website and it basically was
infectious disease doctors or reviewing
charts of patients who came to a clinic
with a respiratory illness and they
determined dissipate if the antibiotics
were basically necessary or not and
unfortunately with this almost 70
million patients half the patients
receive antibiotics and appropriately
and I think that this extrapolates quite
nicely to the inpatient world my world
where these patients commonly still we
get antibiotics and they just simply did
not require antibiotics
looked as I mentioned in 2016 at large
men analysis 11 randomized controlled
trials Cochrane analysis over 4,000
patients looking looking at the use of
PCT versus traditional you know
guidelines and standards
and for sepsis patients when they when
they drill down it showed significantly
reduction in duration and exposure to
antibiotics and the patients who were
utilized with procalcitonin for the
management and look at the bottom here
at the table I frequently get a question
dr. Francine can I just use negative PC
T values and when we have three negative
PC T values and we can discontinue
antibody answers sure yeah you can but
look at the very bottom line and the
patients who have elevated PCTs and they
the clinicians look for an 80% reduction
from a higher value you can still see
there was a statistically significant
reduction in duration exposure to
antibiotics and the patients who were
utilized with PCTs that were elevated
and following them over time to see a
reduction from here was a 23% reduction
overall with antibiotic exposure for the
patients who had PCT utilized versus
controls without
there was no mortality adverse mortality
signal associated with the use of PCT
group for sepsis care and so here is
kind of what it looks like you have your
patient who gets is in the emergency
room and you're evaluating them for your
either in this case sepsis or lower
respiratory tract infection which will
tackle near the end of the talk you're
going to get a baseline procalcitonin
we're talking about a negative
predictive value now something the ER
clinicians may not necessarily be able
to utilize immediately if it's totally
negative you're going to go with your
clinical know-how and you're going to
follow the patient's progress or lack of
overtime with daily procalcitonin levels
up to 96 hours if it's flat or rising
despite what you're doing then you are
concerned that you're missing a source
or you're missing the organism and
that's the patient again who's kind of
flat with their of their clear clinical
progress or lack of and then you have
the patient going downward which is
negative or low PCT levels in a
patient's as clinical status is going in
the right direction a lot of opportunity
then for discontinuation of antibiotics
so we're talking about two patient
groups and I want to distinguish between
them we have our sepsis patients
where you are evaluating them in the
emergency room if I need the baseline
procalcitonin for its negative
predictive value from our emergency room
colleagues and they were going to
monitor them over time looking for less
than 0.5 or an 80% reduction gives us a
potential of discontinuation of
antibiotics and a good in a good with a
good clinical status and then you have
the lower respiratory tract infection
patients who have different values which
we're going to cover on a little better
clearer slide with the actual values but
they come in and they are not sick
compared to the sepsis patients I think
that's a really important thing to
recognize here the patients who are
presenting to the emergency room with
either concerns of COPD exacerbation
bronchitis or pneumonia these patients
do not have sepsis they're less acute
and so we have time to monitor them with
PCT levels and their clinical status
with or without antibiotics and use PCT
to discontinue or not start them
they're not as sick this is just a slide
that looks at an example of a protocol
for the use of PCT my strong bias here
and I've seen it over and over again is
that procalcitonin should be
standardized on a protocol order set
when you allow kind of one-off knockoff
orders through your EMR it really does
it really doesn't go well when you have
a you get you get kind of people who are
not being compliant with the value it's
you're skipping the trend things that to
be quite frank could be could be harmful
when you standardize procaster on an
order set you're allowed to put then
inclusion criteria you can see here
exclusion criteria and then even you
know wrecking recommendations of course
on discontinuation or continuation or
escalation of care based on patient
status and the values this is a really
interesting area in the study that we're
doing right now with a thousand patients
looking at PCP and lactic acid levels
and outcome one of the things we're also
looking at is ER triage and those
patients who don't come to the intensive
care unit who then crash for within 40
hours and then come to the intensive
care unit and so there's a lot of
potential here with the use of PCT in
directing triage from the emergency room
or the and directing an increase in the
aggressiveness of care I'm going to go
over that and a lot has to do with of
course elevated PCP levels and the
outcomes associated with that so we're
going to go over a couple couple studies
and I think this is pretty important
specifically to the audience that we
have today
so I told you before that PCC levels
within each host will correlate with
severity so the sicker you are with any
chose to hire the procalcitonin level
the one other thing to remember which is
quite important is that you can see P
you can see procalcitonin variability
from one patient to the next so you can
have one patient who's got horrible
pneumonia sepsis and their PCP is nine
and you can have another patient with
the same diagnosis same chest x-ray and
presentation their PCT is is 49 but
within each host it will rise depending
on their acuity as they get sicker
this is a study from the emergency
department that was an observational
prospective trial looking 120 patients
with who are adults some of people and
you can see they simply just measured
PCP levels and the higher the PCT levels
are found the patients with septic shock
in this case versus sepsis or sirs or
even non-infectious causes so that kind
of again would alert you potentially if
you have a very you know elevated PCT
you may kind of kind of question what do
you do with that person where you going
to put them and what's and do you need
further imaging for example and you can
see the p-value here 0.001 this is a
small study granted there are many other
out there that looked at procalcitonin
levels in ICU admission patients with
communicating ammonia and you can see
the patients who didn't go to the ICU
had much lower procalcitonin levels the
patients who went to the ICU no surprise
had higher procalcitonin levels it's the
last column there of the delayed ICU
patient the one who didn't go to the ICU
who basically declined and ended up
within 48 hours crashing and coming to
the intensive care unit those patients
have elevated PCP levels compared to
those who didn't go to the ICU and
stayed outside so I think that's a
little bit telling again small numbers
overall and there's some this one equal
patient groups here but we can show you
plenty of other studies that continue to
show that this is a marker for someone
who's not going to do well and and maybe
need a higher level of care another
similar study but it seems a bit
different I'll explain that this is a
study from Phillip chutes a group in in
Europe and the United States so in
Switzerland France in the United States
these are 7,000 basically patients
prospectively studied to try to see if
admission emergency room procalcitonin
levels could predict mortality across
different medical presentations
and including sepsis and it looked at
mortality and and their specific medical
diagnosis and what was found here again
which was that PCT was a very strong
predictor of an independent outcome for
30-day mortality across all different
types of medical diagnosis their ICU
admission risk with a p-value of 0.01
was higher when PCT was elevated their
mortality as I stated and their
readmission rate as well
now and that's all for infectious
patients looking at other non-infectious
presentations such as metabolic
disorders and cardiovascular disease and
even with young patients it looks like
that piece of he also was an independent
predictor of doing poorly and also in
this study has found that TCT when added
to queue sofa improved receiver operator
curves an area under the curve for
sensitivity specificity so I think that
so I've been convinced for a long time
that when PCT is elevated you ain't
going to do as well and so I just begged
the question that when you have
specifically very elevated PCT levels in
sepsis and even in this example maybe
other medical conditions do you do
something different there I think time
time will give us more information with
more studies but that's that's really
what this is what I'm asking
this is a data from Moses trial that
looks at PCP levels over time and
looking at their survival and it looks
like again the higher your piece of
p-value you do poorly but those patients
were your procalcitonin stays flat or
Rises and doesn't drop by 80% or more
over 96 hours those patients do do
poorly
another really I think a good study by
Jensen or critical care medicine it is
basically very simple they ordered PCT
levels on day one in the ER and
subsequent days and looked at patients
outcomes and it showed that the higher
the maximal procalcitonin and those
patients whose pc T's continue to rise
the worse the mortality so I've had
cases in the emergency room
I've have seen PC T's of close to 300
and 270 range I think you need to ask
yourself do you do something different
in those cases is that someone who you
get to the operating room maybe a little
faster than you thought you were is that
somebody who maybe need some additional
imaging you thought it was cellulitis
and you could be you know abscess or
necrotizing infection does that person
get additional imaging and where do you
put that person I think we need more
data on this but where do you put that
person do you just put them on the floor
do you deployment a step down for closer
observation do they go to the ICU
those are the questions we should be
asking and I think there's certainly a
role for PCT and helping you make that
difficult decision
so let's now talk about lower
respiratory tract infections in the
emergency room we're talking about again
COPD bronchitis can you quiet pneumonia
and the use of PCT these patients
present it very difficult sometimes you
know they have some mucous they may or
may not have fevers may or may not have
shortness of breath and they're they're
tough um I think they're they're they're
tough to handle and overwhelmingly
everyone in this call knows that person
was maybe bronchitis it probably is
viral a lot of those patients get
antibiotics and they simply didn't need
those antibiotics
this is the algorithm that the FDA
looked at and looking for lower retro
tract infections and the cutoff values
are a little bit lower than that with
concerns of sepsis and again these
patients are not as sick as sepsis
patients you have time to observe them
you have time to observe them off
antibiotics if their clinical status can
okay okay we'll allow and the cutoff
values here was if it was less than with
0.25 or less it was discouraged to
provide antibiotics to start antibiotics
it was point two six or greater it was
encouraged to provide antibiotics in
those patient groups
you have an option here you can observe
them and admit them
you have and not provide antibiotics
with a PC with less than 0.25 and you
can even repeat the PCT the next day or
if you decided to provide antibiotics
you can repeat the procalcitonin in the
house the next day and even just
continue them the next day I've done
that on multiple multiple times these
are patients who will declare themselves
they're not sick in the overall compared
to sepsis patients so you have time to
observe them and try to avoid
inappropriate antibiotics in them
is a part of the meta-analysis that
looked at the El RTI group as well and
to note there's a thousand patients in
the in the pneumonia group for example
which is you know those are good numbers
looking at those patients with PCT
guidance for their LRT our lower
respiratory tract infection versus not
there was a statistically significant
reduction in antibiotic initiation
and you look at the patients who came to
the emergency room and then were
discharged from the emergency room back
home there was over a 50% reduction in
antibiotic administration
I'm not an ER doctor I'm is a very
difficult job that er providers do one
of the benefits here compared to those
patients who are presenting similar to
the doctor's office versus the emergency
room is that you can get a PCP level on
them in the emergency room and of course
now you you cannot get PCP levels
initially in the office and so you have
this availability of extra data with
your clinical know-how that I think is
beneficial when you're when you're in
the emergency room of those patients who
got admitted to the hospital where PCP
was utilized for LRT I a 38 percent
reduction antibiotic exposure was noted
in those patients
like diagnosis in this meta-analysis you
can see 37% reduction in antibiotic
exposure for communica ammonia
five percent reduction in those with
acute bronchitis I think that's probably
the lowest hanging fruit in these three
patient groups
and a 49% reduction in those patients
with acute exacerbation of COPD the days
of using antibiotics in patients with
COPD for its quote unquote
anti-inflammatory mechanism I think are
over would see this and the problems
that we have in our in our in our
hospitals
so I think the next couple slides are
fun and it really highlights some of the
some of what we just covered so let's go
over some cases cases that taken care of
the use of PCT and we'll highlight a
large majority of what we just talked
about
let's talk about the limitations
limitations of any tests are crucial and
PCTs limitations we talked a little bit
about that with the inflammatory piece
so you can have these kind of two three
four or five elevations a PCT that stays
flat that's someone who's not infected
this is a 58 year old patient with liver
disease who came from a skilled nursing
facility who has pneumonia in the
emergency department with shock and
fevers and respiratory failure on a
mechanical ventilator and sick
everything about you says this person's
got steps is from pneumonia and they're
sick and you can see on day one the
procaster level is 0.16 the next day so
what do you do first of all in the ER
you just use your clinical know-how and
you treat those patients you get to base
on PCT we could potentially use this for
its negative predictive value it may
have been super elevated and you could
use it for its positive predictive value
in terms of escalation of antibiotic
care maybe and you can see the next day
in this case it went to 16 the key here
is you use your clinical know-how and
you treated the patient and this is a
limitation you're going to see some of
these cases and you're going to use your
clinical now and treat them
appropriately and this is just like any
other test I saw a case this week of a
totally negative troponin with horrible
unstable angina multiple negative
troponin levels EKGs not doing much you
ended up needing two staggered you know
stenting procedures and so you're going
to see this with PCT as well as other
other biomarkers
this is a 78 year old patient with a
sore throat and respiratory failure
who's got thought to be sepsis on
antibiotics on mechanical ventilation
and over time as you can see in the
bottom all the PCs PCTs are very
negative at point 1 and less than point
1 and less than point 1 over and over
and over again this person's got a lots
of gas at a 4 ohm with 4 and a half
that's all about perfusion this is an
actual digitalized copy of the plan for
the patient where we had we had CT the
neck and with this we followed PCT we
initially provided antibody this is just
a mono mono viral infection for a
patient with with an opportunity where
in this case DC all antibiotics you can
see right in the line here's the key
this person was sick you didn't just
stop antibiotics in the emergency room
we needed that baseline PC T value so
that over time in this case we could
discontinue with more confidence in
having a good clinical status and
multiple negative negative ba Pro Costa
Luna values in this case I want you to
note that the viral panel was also
positive and I loved the combination of
a positive rapid viral panel and a
negative procalcitonin you have a lot of
confidence there about what you're
dealing with this negative Pro cast
Turner in this case is showing us that
there is it's very unlikely that there's
are bacterial super infection
this is a 38 year old male with diabetes
who suffered a prolonged cardiac arrest
and then fortunately improve their neuro
status and in the emergency room has a
procalcitonin of 34 on exam this person
looks like they got cellulitis and you
can get a PCT of 34 you get with
cellulite Scott it's kind of high
they got antibiotics appropriately from
the ER providers and they were treated
for their cellulitis and then you can
see we follow their clinical statuses
patient just kind of wouldn't come off
pressors and the PCP came down with
antibiotics and then it starts going
back up again and in this case that
prompted me to get a CT scan of the leg
and we found necrotizing fasciitis
patient required amputation ended up
surviving the hospitalization although a
long hospitalization so I just wanted to
draw the attention back to a couple
things number one PCT will stay flat
arise if you're missing the organism in
terms of antibiotic selection and number
two and in this case PCT will will stay
flat or rise in when you haven't got
source control if you haven't drained
the hydro nifer osis it wasn't just
simple urinary tract infection your PCT
and the patient's clinical status are
going to show you otherwise that goes
the same with perforations abdominal
that goes the same with in this case a
necrotizing infection that required
amputation so you're always going to go
with your clinical know-how but you're
going to combine it in this case just
kind of a flat presentation just
wouldn't come off you know cantilever
fed or so in this case prompted us to
get CT scan and I think the same goes
for emergency room management when you
see very very high maximal procalcitonin
levels that's that's best that can be
telling and that potentially would
change what you do with imaging and
considering again as I stated that your
PCT rises in the sicker the patient is
is a 78 year old male with a history of
heart failure in the SS 15% who's got a
defibrillator and comes in with
respiratory failure with that chest
x-ray emitted by our extenders with
bilateral infiltration edema patients
got no fever no white count and does not
get antibiotics and then within the next
morning look at that chest x-ray I don't
know what that is I mean he's got a huge
heart and it's got a disturb you later
and looks like edema and got a lot of
associated things on chest x-ray that
would push for that but no fever normal
white count could be pneumonia I guess
and then we had Elaine antibiotics here
with a pro cast owner that comes back at
almost 38 which then prompts antibiotic
administration and then later in the day
fever of 103 and so again back to
somewhat of what was a surprise
procalcitonin or in this case helps with
a difference with diagnosis between
pulmonary edema and CHF maybe would have
gotten antibiotics little quicker if we
if we maybe had the PCT in this in this
circumstance a little earlier so I I'm
going to roll through some of our
references in the next couple slides but
I really want to spend some some good
time and answering questions further
from from the audience happy to provide
these references to anyone who who would
like to utilize them and I really
appreciate the your your the audience
here and let's look look forward to some
some good questions
thank you dr. Feinstein for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. Feinstein will answer as many
questions as time permits so the first
question is have you used Vitus brahms
procalcitonin also known as PCT results
and filmer a respiratory panel result
together to make clinical decisions in
patients with lower respiratory tract
infection and if so can you tell me how
and provide an example
yeah great great question I think this
is a this is kind of on the forefront
really we're living in in a world now a
rapid identification which is super
right took ten years ago we just simply
didn't have this stuff and when you can
gain when you can have a positive viral
panel which is going to telling you now
a part of the difference of diagnosis
you kind of have a better idea what
started this meta Numa virus positive
flu and now a negative procalcitonin
which is then giving you information
about is there a bacterial super
infection that that really brings a lot
of confidence to discontinuation of
antibiotics on day one day two or day
even day three I mean but but certainly
discontinuing antibiotics in providing
shorter shorter durations thank you next
one is on average how many PCT samples
do you envision being taken on a patient
in the emergency department prior to
being triage to the ICU or is it worth
waiting until the patient arrives to the
ICU
so I put this in the same category of
lactic acid level you kind of want that
as soon as possible that's why we have
we have point-of-care testing we
remember trying to skip the lat some
delays in lab you want to get the PCT I
think pretty immediately you want to
then correlate it with the patient's
clinical status in front of you as a
clinician who does the admissions and
are in our friendly hospitalists we got
to have the baseline PCT to you really
in the ER to use that to look for 80%
reduction going forward and for the
negative predictive value on the same
token I think you want to get the PCP
immediately in the emergency room to
correlate it with your patient's
clinical status for the positive
predictive value so the answer is you
want to get it right then and there
essentially when you're getting your
other lactic acid and other sepsis
workup
thank you next one is we are trying to
program in an algorithm within our EHR
to monitor procalcitonin levels as an
indication to pharmacy for antibiotic
de-escalation what criteria would you
recommend we tried monitoring for a 25%
drop but this loses significance when
the baseline procalcitonin is already
very small
yeah that's a great question so get your
iPhone calculator out because I you know
you really should stick with the 80%
reduction as the FDA has has recommended
over the up to 96 hours when you have
mature PCT programs like like you you do
get potentially other opportunities as
you get very comfortable with it but I
think you really should stick with the
FDA claim with the 80% reduction and if
you have these low values I you know
it's a great question I think I'd still
stick with 80% reduction when you have
these values less than three and four
I don't think that the literature is
going to suggest otherwise for sepsis
patients right now I just don't want any
harm to come you know from that from
from your patient groups thank you
insurance companies consider PCT as
investigational for example they do not
pay for the tests done in the emergency
room on outpatients how do you justify
the costs
you're referring to ER patients who then
kind of go home so all I can do is make
an extrapolation so first of all you
could avoid antibiotics for a patient
who then again didn't need them and of
course I know you're we all think the
same way which is of course there's
negative aspects to giving people
antibiotics from from their standpoint
from reactions and just you know c-diff
and frequent exposure so I know that US
clinician want to avoid that but in
terms of cost let's extrapolate from Bob
bulk study in chess in 2016 that's
that's all I can basically do because
there's not a whole lot of data out
there that looks closely at the
financials for that specific patient who
comes to the ER then goes home but the
bottom line in bob box it was a
retrospective review and premier data in
sepsis patients looking at those who got
one or two PCTs and in your case you're
getting one it was 33,000 patients who
got PCT algorithm versus ninety-eight
thousand those who did not and it showed
a total reduction in money that was
required of a close to three thousand
dollars in each patient who had PCT
algorithm utilized versus not and that
was a p-value of 0.01 so I think and
just in my mind I don't have a lot of
common sense at home but in medicine I
got common sense and my sense is that
this would extrapolate just fine with
that patient from a financial burden to
healthcare of reducing reducing
financial burden using PCT thank you how
long did it take you to implement these
changes in your emergency department and
what is your compliance rate with PC
testing with IDI providers
it takes it takes it takes it sometime
it probably takes up to 12 months or so
I think it's you have to be fair to your
air providers they have to get used to
seeing PCT levels and clinical
presentations so I've never measured the
compliance and prior hospitals but I did
measure it initially in 2011 and study
in our critical care patients and the
compliance quite frankly really wasn't
that good it got it gets better over
time with the maturity of a program and
standardizing it on an order set with
recommendations that's my my
recommendation to you would be making
sure that you have a standard standard
algorithm protocol that really allows
some information to be provided for an
education just crucial right you have
turnover in ER providers and nurses
physicians and you just need to continue
the going down the path of education but
but don't lose hope I think this is this
is like a 12-month process or 18-month
process of improving improvement
compliance
thank you next one is how do you
recommend interpreting PCT in patients
with chronic kidney disease acute kidney
injury and end-stage renal disease yep
super question love it so let's tackle
and stage renal first because in my mind
they're different than acute kidney
injury patients to some extent there's
about 15 studies out there looking at
the clearance of end-stage renal for PCT
it's probably about 10 to 15 percent of
PCT is cleared through the kidneys so
those patients are going to see him I
have cases where they come in and their
PCP is four and a half it just stays
flat that's not someone who's
bacterially infected we may not have
sepsis at all or LRT I and so if that
same patient comes in two weeks later
and their piece of the drums 2:15 which
I've seen and their baseline started at
and it drops from it drops then to 7:00
and drops cough 3 well that's someone
who trended up and trended down and they
had an infection present so you can use
it in a patient group it's very
similarly what I'm talking about
patients who are on the vending machine
with a RDS they may have this kind of
PCT value of two three four five and it
kind of goes up and it comes down that's
someone who's got that or concerns with
bacterial infection in terms of acute
kidney infection we need studies we
don't have them in terms of acute kidney
failure and from my antidotal experience
I really think that the PCT tracks
upward slightly with acute renal failure
creatinine's and worsening GFR and then
comes back down I think when it when it
recovers but we just don't have data on
that patient group so I would treat the
patient with acute kidney injury in
general similar one who doesn't have the
acute kidney injury thank you we're
getting so many great questions coming
in the next one is how long is a
reasonable amount of time in which to
expect a PCP result from the lab ok
great question
I really think 30 minutes is really
where this test needs to be you're going
to act on it so got a positive
predictive value and there's there's
been a few studies out there that of
them had delays up to 8 hours and their
PCT results and it affects patient
management and patient decisions i I
really there was one study that had an
alert associated with the PCT bypass and
because there was a delay to delay to
the PCT they got it really it really I
think hindered patient care so I think
30 minutes is something that a health
system should be shooting for you really
should not be sending this out that she
needs to be in house thank you can you
discuss why pediatric patients are not
included in the PCT based exclusion
criteria is this lack of studies or just
PCP you respond differently in pediatric
patients okay cool
great question
neonates at 72 hours or less you can
have issues with false PCTs
but over 72 hours I think that the
pediatric population responds very
similarly then to adults this is this is
why we don't have a tremendous amount of
research in pediatric populations right
because it's the caution and cause
appropriate caution and the patient
group but there's a lot of success
tremendous amount of success in using
PCT in pediatric populations all over
this country over 72 hours and they it's
just it's just weariness and concern of
that population in general but this is
something to see a massive growth in the
use of PCT in pediatrics over the next
five years and of all the populations oh
my god this is the patient group that
gets inappropriate antibiotics and we
needed we need to concentrate on so I
just think it's just lagging behind and
it'll get there thank you would you say
your recommended sepsis panel would be
PCT c-reactive protein and lactate
testing
so I'm not a big proponent of c-reactive
protein so it's so nonspecific doesn't
do much for profusion but absolutely PCT
and a lactic is something that I'd be
combining yes thank you
is there a push with CMS guidelines and
the sepsis guidelines to suggest use of
PCP instead of lactic acid no see me at
CMS guidelines are right on target with
making sure that we are using lactic
acid for perfusion you probably will see
in time the recommendation of PCT being
added to that but again these are just
different markers with different
purposes and I hope with this study that
we're embarking on here will give us
some information about how to use them
synergistically but you should not be
off doing anything instead of sorry
about that how often should PCT be done
in a 24-hour period from the ICU yeah
great question I think that the package
insert would tell you can use it up to
you know 12 hours or so there's people
who in end-stage we know these patients
will use it every 8 to 12 hours in
general that is not been my experience I
really think that you get it immediately
in the mergency room you get it the next
morning on an algorithm standardized
protocol that automatically gets in the
next morning and gets it in the next
morning and you can make a decision
about the next morning which is up to 96
hours but I think my past experience has
been that we have had good success with
getting it immediately no matter what
time it really is you know 10 a.m. or
even 10 p.m. and then getting it the
next morning on a standardized protocol
and then the next morning after that
thank you
for a hospital that has not yet adopted
PCT testing where would be a good place
to start to get the best outcomes to
validate utilization
yeah good question so first of all the
this push should really be coming from
the clinicians you know the clinicians a
tidy and critical care and hospitals er
the other ones who should be raising
their hand to say we think we we think
we need this I have a my personal bias
it's just from my experience level that
you need to start out with a negative
predictive value you need to use it for
antibiotic stewardship first and
foremost and not necessary for its
positive predictive value of seeing if
it you know kind of surprises you that
you know you you should be looking at
the negative predictive value for
antibiotic stewardship from the
beginning and you're going to see
reasonable results in reducing days of
therapy per 1000 patient days which will
kind of keep you solid with not having
senses impact that thank you as a
laboratory technologist how can we help
assign the emergency room when it comes
to PCT assist I'm sorry as a laboratory
technologist how can we help assist the
ER when it comes to PCT well I think it
just it comes with a turnaround time and
having having a proper independent
machine of the Vitis brahms PCT to to be
used and making sure that you get it and
understand that it is a priority for the
clinicians on the other side to get that
information within 20 to 30 minutes that
this you can't batch this you can't and
should not batch this this test so I
think that be your responsibility to
come up with with something amongst your
team in the lab that does it and gets it
provided with in timely manner when
would you recommend repeat PCT in the
emergency department when the first PCT
is negative
however clinical presentation has high
suspicion of infection and the
hospitalists are not sure about
admission with first-
PCT
I've never been asked a question I think
it's a superb awesome question I think
the answer is first of all you're going
to go with your clinical mal so if they
don't look good and your concern then
admit them and get it next morning on
the other hand if you if they look at
you're not quite sure your minimum or
not minim you know I don't think there's
a good answer out there but I have some
colleagues and other states and things
that do it in eight hours maybe you put
them an observation peer and you get it
in eight hours
certainly the package answer it would
say that you could do it in 12 hours but
you know if this thing rises pretty
rapidly so I think you could you can
make an argument to getting it earlier
within four hour four to six again four
to eight hours in an observation type of
area I doubt you want to keep them in
your merchants room that long thank you
the next one has several parts so just
let me know if you need me to repeat all
three journal first do you have any
comments on some of the more recent
literature on looking at PCT values
specifically in lower respiratory tract
infections in the emergency department
for example the recent study by David
Wong at all published in the New England
Journal of Medicine in 2018 reported
that when looking at lower lower
respiratory tract infections in the
emergency department they found no
difference in total antibiotic days
patients that received any antibiotics
or antibiotic days during hospital stay
between patients that were ordered a PCT
versus those that were not
it seems more recent literature than
what was cited in the presentation has
found PCT less useful in regards to
lower respiratory tract infections in
the emergency department specifically we
are looking at antibiotic use yeah I
mean I'm glad you're bringing this up
it's a great thing you're bringing up
and certainly I read that article and
here's the key of the disappointment of
that study and I can speak from my own
experience when you have procalcitonin
mature programs is when you get
compliance and you get good results from
the use of discontinuation of
antibiotics and a negative predictive
value and unfortunately with a new
internal study the biggest
disappointment is overwhelmingly
everyone involved in that trial never
use PCT before
they didn't probably have the confidence
in the experience level that other
providers who've had experience like
then the meta-analysis of using PCT had
and I think I don't think is a small
thing I think that's a big thing so I
agree with you that we need more trials
in L RTI but I think that that study was
discounted substantially for me because
none of the providers had experienced
with PCT prior thank you so it looks
like we have time for one more question
could a right lower quadrant pain
patient with low PCT and normal CBC be
considered very low risk of acute
appendicitis
I'll go with a no on that one I I would
just come back to the most important
premise which is use your clinical no
he'll you got a lot of rhetoric quadrant
tenderness and PCTs negatives I just
still that person could go down pretty
quickly you know you miss the diagnosis
of acute cholecystitis you you don't
resuscitate you don't give fluids you
don't investigate further I know you
gather you mentioned the red oak
quadrant ultrasound you might want to
still kind of correlate that with a CT
even if pcs negative
getting more data all studies have
sensitivity and specificity all studies
have negative negative false negatives
including PCT a right upper quadrant
Alex downs and CTS so my sense on that
question is just go to clinical no house
still let the dust settle provide care
that's based on what your presentation
looks like and then maybe correlate with
a cat scan with the right upper quadrant
repeat the Pichichi the next morning
thank you I would like to once again to
thank dr. flame Steen for his
presentation do you have any final
comments
no appreciate the the questions were
superb and I think that we we've got
ourselves something here that's that
certainly has lasted the test of time in
terms of a sepsis bacterial infection
marker and the data just continues to -
over overall go in the right direction
and again I would I would try to
standardize the use of PCC in your
health systems that's going to be a
significant in terms of success for
everybody thank you I would also like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor bu area for
underwriting today's educational webcast
until next time goodbye